what is going on there reject nation greg
here today to talk about doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness specifically i wanted
to jump in on the conversation about mutants a
lot of people are speculating that mutants will
finally be introduced through this movie and i
have a theory that may sound a little far-fetched
at first but if you stick with me on this journey
you'll see where i'm coming from hopefully so if
you guys could go ahead and hit that like button
i very much appreciate it and let's just dive
right into this so before even the fox merger
even happened the big question has been when will
mutants come into the mcu there's been a lot of
popular theories floating about one theory being
thanos's staff created mutations in human genes
another popular theory is that the eternals
already set up mutants because in the comics
the genetic experiments that the celestials
performed created the x gene and another popular
theory i was hearing going about was that the
dreaming celestial at the end of the movie the
energy emitted from that celestial kick-started
the mutant gene now after eternals we still
haven't heard anything about mutants what has
been like the common theory for doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness mutants will be
introduced via the multiverse and then through
a series of cataclysmic events it will result in
presumably wanda maximoff aka the scarlet witch
essentially rewriting parts of the
mcu timeline in which mutants do exist
presumably the fox x-men universe opening the
door for essentially a multiversal rewrite or
reset allowing the birth of mutants to exist
within the main universe so in short it would
be a reversal from what happens in the house
of m comics you might have heard this comic
brought up a lot in that comic scarlet witch
is the main threat and in the end of the story
she blames mutants for the world's problems
using her reality bending abilities she declares
the famous words no more mutants so the common
theory is that this movie would end essentially
in a reversal of that with like a let there
be mutants which sounds cool that sounds fine
but my theory is this what if the mcu timeline
we've been watching for the last 13 years
no more mutants has already happened like i said
i know this sounds like a bit of a reach however
i think this would answer some questions we've had
about the mcu questions specifically regarding the
events of wanda vision i think it would better
help reintroduce x-men and mutants into the
marvel cinematic universe and with this phase
after wanda vision loki the demon the trailer
for moon night this is called multiverse of
madness this is the mind-bending phase of the mcu
what more of a mind-bender would it be than to
reveal to us that mutants were already there and
that the actions of the scarlet witch erasing the
existence of mutants already happened dive into
this with me spider-man no way home that showed
us it's possible to erase people from the world's
memory including doctor strange via forgetting who
peter parker was spoilers for spider-man no way
what if this movie takes it the next step further
since wanda vision was announced everyone has been
looking to the house of m comic book that's like
the go-to source material to better understand and
perhaps predict what might happen in the marvel
cinematic universe now that's an important comic
but the comic that i'd recommend looking into
is actually one of the follow-ups the house of
m x-men endangered species in that comic after the
existence of mutants has already been reduced from
millions to only hundreds around the world hank
mccoy aka beast sets out on a journey to find a
way to reverse the spell wanda cast and along this
journey he eventually meets up with dr strange who
tells him exactly this what she did completely
change reality that it's nearly impossible to see
where reality ends and her alteration of it begins
she cast her spell over billions of souls over
worlds and dimensions reality has been consumed
by her spell the magic is woven through everything
welded to all there is so in the source material
itself doctor strange declares her spell affected
worlds and dimensions i.e the multiverse i tried
rhyming that didn't quite work so the main rumor
ever since this movie was announced at comic-con
is that wanda maximoff will be the main villain
of this movie and another rumor that's been
circulating is that the illuminati might be
featured in this movie and they would essentially
act as protectors of the multiverse who are here
to stop multiversal threats with this being a
doctor strange movie with the few appearances
that we got of scarlet witch in a movie about
traveling the multiverse why would wanda
maximoff be considered the ultimate threat to the
multiverse is it because the illuminati believe
in witchcraft lore i don't think so maybe this
is the real reason why agatha harkness who once
possessed the darkhold which grants access to the
multiverse told wanda you're supposed to be a myth
so am i saying that we're in some repeated time
loop where the wanda we've been with the whole
time has already done this no i'm not saying that
loki has already introduced us to variants so as
we saw in the setup of that show a variant of our
protagonist was considered a multiversal threat so
what if in another universe the events of wanda
maximoff being brought to the breaking point of
mutants already played out and she declared
no more mutants affecting all the timelines
especially the one that we've been watching for
the last 13 years spider-man no way home showed
us that just because variants exist does not mean
they are running on exactly the same timeline case
in point toby maguire's peter parker for sure
his character is a lot older than tom holland's
peter parker this could be a similar thing with
wanda maximoff just in another universe with the
powers the scarlet witch possesses her ability to
warp reality combine that with the ending events
of loki where all that timelines were starting to
intersect and began crossing practices went into
chaos that could explain why some things in wanda
vision registered to her as familiarity which were
brand new to us even to her for example the one
division series would lead us to believe that
tommy and billy were just something she imagined
up that she gave birth to and in like a week
went from babies into these preteens and for
some reason stopped growing at that specific
age yet when she's using the dark hole at the
end of wanda vision accessing the multiverse
she hears tommy and billy crying out for
her essentially the show's way of telling us
these children are not purely imagination but in
fact real children her mind could be connected to
a variant of herself that already declared no
more mutants in order to have a rewritten life
so she could have the family she wanted a line
that stood out to us in that show was when she
tells her children thanks for choosing me to
be your mom isn't it just a little bit odd that
if she does traverse the multiverse find tommy
and billy that they are indeed exactly like how
she imagined in our universe and even take evan
peters showing up in wanda vision as frustrating
as it was to learn that he's just some guy called
ralph boner believe me i didn't like that either
but i thought about it some more when he shows
up at their doorstep she instantly recognizes
him despite the fact that he looks and behaves
totally different than aaron taylor johnson she
recognizes he is indeed pietro we come to find
out it's not but agatha needed someone that upon
wanda seeing would instantly recognize as her
brother even though wanda at one point questions
why do you look different she still recognizes him
as her sibling maybe perhaps she's connected to a
variant version of herself where her brother
looks like evan peters maybe the fox universe
here's where i'm coming from to introduce mutants
into the mcu it's a major change-up and would
drastically affect the timeline if they wanted
to adhere to the source material if it was like
ah mutants now exist now we gotta like kind of do
some of the prejudice allegories that that comic
draws so like even though the mcu does deviate
from source material the mutants have been around
since practically like the beginning of time and
they grew to be more known to the world by the
20th century and in the marvel cinematic universe
we've already had events like avengers and games
were countless heroes many with superpowers super
beings came together to defeat a universe doom
threat a big part of bringing mutants to the big
screen like you just have to have this if you're
gonna bring mutants is dealing with the hatred
humans have against mutants dealing with the
racism allegories now in the mcu after all these
super beings have done for us and just how much
they're celebrated i'm just having a hard time
wrapping my head around the thought of humanity
just suddenly singling out mutants specifically
if they were to be introduced as brand new beings
into the mcu timeline plain and simple you just
can't do mutants without the inclusion of the
the prejudices it presents so maybe the way to
handling it is restoring the mutants into the mcu
causing everyone to remember their animosity
towards mutants before the legendary words
of i am iron man well i just don't think it's
that far fetch of a plan any more so didn't
like let's just smash multiverses together and to
create mutants kevin feige the man of many secrets
unusually unveiled a while ago the alternate
post-credits scene for iron man this isn't
like something kind of like out of the
ordinary for the guy to do and everything
he says and does presents is so intentional and in
that post-credits scene one thing that nick fury
says is this as if gamma accidents radioactive
bug bites and assorted mutants weren't enough
why would kevin feige unveil their original plan
to us maybe because he was hinting that mutants
were already there the original post credit
scene which was actually scripted and filmed
indicated that there are mutants living amongst
us and hiding some believe that perhaps the best
way to introduce mutants would be they've been
in hiding and now feel comfortable to come out
but mutants come in the form of millions not
just a few who are banned together like hiding
like the eternals it's not something like that
original post-credits scene would line up with
the idea that there are currently only hundreds
of mutants and not millions of mutants just like
house of m anyway guys that's just my little
film theory for today and that's just a theory
a film theory but yeah guys what do you think
tell me how ridiculous it sounds tell me if you
think it sounds plausible at all what's
your theory of how mutants will come to
the mcu thank you so much for joining
me on this journey catch you guys soon